so the uh question SL comment is on the
ukim on the sword okay so uh first we
have to make sure that the Joe is
actually penetrating and not kissing the
front of my body okay he goes and it's
pen trading boom out comes my weapon so
we do again I want you to listen to
something okay listen this is version
a hear that sound I'll do it again
version
a version
B can you hear that difference do it
again version
a version
B so a
b
a a b
okay um I'm not trying to touch the
surface of his weapon I'm trying to just
like uh when I touch him here I'm not
trying to touch his arm not trying to
touch his arm trying to touch his
Center his Center not not this touch
here but in his Center same thing on his
[Music]
weapon in his Center okay so he's going
to go and I'm going to touch his Center
again
again you hear the
difference okay so when he goes now I
can feel
it here oh po I'm not going to feel it
here feel his body
P you go
quicker okay and again
listen
loose
through his
SP okay so you have to change what you
think you're doing just like on his arm
you feel for where his Center is not
touching just here okay so same
thing touching his Center touching his
Center the whole time
okay all right give it a
[Music]
shot
[Applause]
first thing on the on the machia toilet
okay if
I the the question was I feel a lot of
tension in my back okay um well set
yourself up for a success all right if
I'm doing something with my body that
lends itself more towards tension than
does not then I better be more skilled
at releasing okay so that's going to be
less successful as I'm trying to learn
releasing okay so uh try to remember
that makos happens at third Joe don't
come out at half Joe okay you can you
can there's already tension here as I'm
trying to do that all right so as I was
watching your Technique uh and some of
some of you others are doing this is
when you go to ski you have this arm so
extended you see like this that one you
would get cut with his hand movement and
you're s your
hand deeper into the fight which doesn't
make Marshall sense that's why you have
a weapon you see that you're sticking
your hand out there which you would cut
it but you're now not in third J okay so
you do that you're out here like that
and we go and there's just a lot of
tension a lot of tension to hold it
there you want to be relaxed okay and
you'll find more relax ability potential
at third Joe then holding this thing out
there which does not make Marshall sense
okay so as we
go he's going to
go what is key here is also that as he's
trying to connect with my
Center I have to counter that so I'm
going to counter his connection to my
center by rotating the cross so I'm
going to come around it this way do you
see and now now he's not connecting with
my center and I'm going to come down and
connect with his Center at a new
connection Point here at the tuba into
the
strike all right so I have to void he
goes He voided there I come up he seeks
connection and I'm going to
void I have to release for that if he
feels my
tension which I will be because I feel
him you see and then you put your arm
out here oh yeah yeah yeah there's a lot
of tension in here what I'm going to do
is
relax okay into his
body as I watch your
Technique you have to be careful of this
coming around you're too close to this
sub angle and you get this little baby
hit
this weapon
here and you get that full ax that full
rotating cross before you come down
don't start moving down and now you got
that little baby hit Okay so we're here
you're going to watch this weapon turn
right at the point of his connection
that's where my weapon turns you see and
then that comes down don't don't keep
going this way
here
and into the center okay so your point
third Joe rotating cross for both of you
and then we'll add that third thing and
you you should be able he grabs you
should be able to project his Center the
same way that I did there I should be
able to do on the Makia part I don't
want to
oh just hit his hands you see that it
goes from here into the center into
Center okay let's
go so look how this is going to be your
my is wrong
okay so your M's wrong again you're
moving up the circle move back out there
you go
and then that has to aim into his Center
not his
hands
[Applause]
down
so let's let's say I wanted to to punch
you okay I
don't get your job I don't want to hit
the surface I don't want to hit the
surface okay I I want
to penetrate through the target you see
that now as I penetrate through the
target though I don't want it to be a
push you see that it's still
ballistic do you see that
okay going
do it's all right don't say
sorry
when you touch my after you touch my
hands I want you to stop moving don't
get out of the
technique okay stay there stay there
hold hold this position don't press down
anymore okay stay
there so right now all of your weight is
lower than this part you see that so
basically you're pulling it down you
understand that yes and so that means
this part is heavy push down do you
see that's going to make this part light
and that's why you can't hit my hands
let it alone affect my cental it's not a
lightsaber okay so we'll trade
rules I'm not going to hit your hand
right we'll get there cool okay so
you're going down here look here you
see lift your sword
up
okay what I'm going to
do is here and I'm going to start to
change this angle not keep dropping so
this is going to push down down down
down down down down down down you see
and at this point I
drw okay so let go your book
in push my tip up you see how light it
is push my tip
up you see the difference okay
so you can't just do the shape there's a
timing to the shape boom boom can't go
here I have to go
okay do you see that difference yes
okay down
again
okay but you're probably
wondering how do I get on the other side
you see you get it okay but you already
shot all your load on dropping your wave
now this is
wi don't leave it there as we go slow
motion okay so I'm going to come around
just enough you see heav
dropped just enough to go around that
without contesting it just enough you
see then I bring this into that
shape okay go
there
okay try it timeing yeah okay so now
from the other
hand key on this one is you're not
hitting him on the spin there's no power
on it so you're going to do to boom and
then you come up and it'll spin but
there's no pause there okay so boomp two
hands into the two hands
h okay let's
try I say just do the move cuz I showed
you the move okay right if you need some
reason it could
be that my Spar end is on the other
side I'm using different ends of the
weapon and I want to now spear him okay
so I'm going to turn the spear or it
could be I don't want to spear him I
just want to butt him
okay I'm more interested in the
coordination can you feel your lack of
coordination okay particularly the
moving fluid mind if you have to moov M
and you want it to be one move got it so
you're going here you're here and you're
oh yeah
okay it's it's got to
be one
move but it can't be oneh handed okay so
it's one
move
okay still has to be in his Center okay
here we
[Music]
go same thing stuck okay then
see stuck
not you're all
right okay let TR
okay so uh it's the stickiness that I
wanted to
work stick boom stick he goes
boom stick and
again in his body you see not here on
his
weapon in his body
okay
stop stop pull your Joe
back stuck stuck stuck stuck
okayu in his
body okay now
the
timing will go slow usually what's
happening is as you go and he's taking
your
Center you get a little
check and it's too
late that ski is going to be
there so what you're trying to do
instead is
yield to his rotating cross I just
rotated it again
look he rotated it and I rotated it
again oh you have to in other words you
have to counter his counter
okay that way your Center is not being
attacked by
him okay but
when you do
that rotate
home don't dis hit his
weapon your
weight is in your hand on the end just
like his makos was in his body
okay
okay you can hear it stick your weapon
out okay go